[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez master rosa bienvenida allá
feliz martes feliz mañana que sé cómo se
sentiría usted rosa si estuviera
indocumentada en su propia tierra en su
propio país pues sin muchos derechos
igual que siendo indocumentada pues en
un país que ya no es el propio no
igualmente es una situación complicada
es que rosa lo traigo a colación porque
así hay un artículo del país
indocumentados en su propia tierra los 3
millones de brasileños invisibles qué
pasa con estas personas bien es que es
un reportaje que hemos querido
seleccionar del país raúl porque aborda
un problema que si bien se ha reducido
en las últimas dos décadas en brasil
continúa afectando aproximadamente a 3
millones de personas como se trata de
personas que no tienen certificado de
nacimiento pues evidentemente es
complicado cuantificar a cuánta gente
digamos atañe esta problemática pero
aquí una de las protagonistas del
reportaje es adriana que tiene 22 años
pero tal cómo empieza este texto adriana
tiene 22 años pero aún no ha nacido y
bien oficialmente no evidentemente
estamos hablando y se trata de como
comentábamos la ausencia de certificados
de nacimiento por distintas razones en
la texto aboca cuestiones de abandono
paterno en otros casos de racismo o de
machismo de no querer inscribir a los
hijos por ser demasiado negros o por ser
niñas en lugar de niños lo que complica
pues exceso a una educación pública
también a la salud adriana en este caso
comenta en sus dificultades pues por
poderse vacunarse contra la cob y 19 y
el en el texto se citan distintas
fuentes entre juego una jueza
especializada en la materia como una
periodista que lleva años investigando
la cuestión y que apunta como una de las
soluciones que los centros educativos o
los centros sanitarios de viven
activamente a las personas que se
encuentran indocumentadas pues al
registro civil rosa nos vamos perfilando
a las elecciones presidenciales de
francia el año que viene y por eso vamos
a ir
diarios limón y liberación hablamos de
la candidatura oficial de eric somos
exacto raúl es una candidatura que se
acaba de oficializar hace apenas una
hora al mediodía
hora de parís y eric de moore se trata
de una pole mixta podríamos llamarlo así
de extrema derecha francés de 70 63 años
muy habitual de los platos pues de
francia no de las televisiones de las
radios donde siempre incendia el debate
con sus comentarios pues de extrema
derecha de hecho hay mucha gente que lo
compara con tram no cualquier
declaración que hace finalmente es
amplificada por los medios de
comunicación por lo incendiaria que
resulta bien acaba de oficializar su
candidatura a las presidenciales de 2022
donde pretende agrupar a la derecha y a
la extrema derecha no haciendo un poco
la competencia a marine lepén incluso
marín le pegan en la candidata del
frente nacional renombrado reagrupación
nacional lo ha calificado de demasiado
extremista no raúl bueno vamos a ir
siguiendo esta campaña
papel ocupa lo que está claro es que
candidatos como el ha derechizado
completamente el espectro político
francés al cierre os ahora vamos con the
nation dar a josephine baker una tumba
heroína no enterrar a la verdad porque
dice esto bien porque es un autor que
parte de su experiencia personal de hace
tan sólo unos años cuando era estudiante
en la francia es un autor británico
negro que comenta ya el racismo que él
sufrió viviendo en este país europeo y
que comenta que si bien a principios del
siglo 20 francia podía ser un lugar una
escapatoria para muchos
afroestadounidenses en comparación con
lo que vivían en eeuu ahora es un país
se llama donde se vive una el racismo
republicano tal y como lo llama el tanto
por controles de la policía por perfil
racial tanto como por el propio gobierno
de macrón que ha calificado de enemigos
de la república incluso a las
universidades que hablan de teorías de
coloniales o interseccional es raúl y
vamos a terminar con the gardian
barbados se separan en la reina isabel y
se convierte en la república más joven
del mundo rosa exacto esta es una
crónica desde la capital de barbados
desde brigestone donde se escenificó
este a esta transición no de monarquía
parlamentaria a una república
parlamentaria
recordemos lo que sucede es que la reina
isabel segunda reina de la commonwealth
ya deja de ser la jefa de estado de esta
nación a caribeño y ahora pasan pues a
tener una presidenta del país que es que
ocupa la jefatura de forma pues también
simbólica se trata de sandra manson y
recordamos que el sistema que adopta
barbados es el de república
parlamentaria algo parecido a lo que
tiene alemania digamos donde el poder
del ejecutivo recae sobre la figura del
primer ministro que en alemania
conocemos como canciller no y la
jefatura del estado este presidente es
más bien una cuestión simbólica y
también destaca que ayer en esta
ceremonia se nombró a rihanna como
heroína del país no una de las figuras
pop pues más conocidas
desde origen caribeño y también destacar
que isabel segundo a si bien no estaba
en la ceremonia si estaba presente a su
hijo el príncipe carlos que dijo desde
los días más oscuros de nuestro pasado a
la espantosa atrocidad de la esclavitud
que manchó para siempre nuestra historia
el pueblo de esta isla forjó su camino
con extraordinaria fortaleza y es que
esta crónica relación a la haya voluntad
dice definitiva de independencia de
barbados con la ola anti racista que se
vivió el año pasado alrededor del mundo
después del asesinato de heart flight en
eeuu y de rosa y como ya estamos viendo
imágenes de lo que fue entonces esta
juramentación el ya entonces barbados
pasa a ser la república más joven del
mundo rosa gracias por toda la
información nos vemos mañana con más
revista de prensa vamos ahora a
conversar con esa primera invitada al
día